sí Ángela buenas tardes bueno el primero
de ellos como tú decías es que el
presidente nuevamente hizo entender a la
gente a través de la televisión de que
esta reforma es necesaria El Recuerdo No
es cierto que son en Francia los activos
los que pagan la jubilaciones de las
personas mayores y que cada vez las
personas envejecen más por lo tanto
volvió a insistir en que este sistema no
cierto está en una situación delicada
financiera y que por lo tanto no hay
otra opción y como tú decías a fin de
año este proyecto esta ley tendría ya
que exponerse en efecto a su juicio
también obviamente habló de las
manifestaciones de hecho anoche en una
reunión con los diputados de la mayoría
había dicho justamente que la multitud
no tenía la legitimidad que tienen las
personas el pueblo que se expresa a
través de sus diputados o sus
autoridades electas volvió a insistir en
eso hizo el Paralelo con Brasil con los
Estados Unidos y que a él a esa gente a
esa gente que manifiesta de manera
violenta no es a la que va a escuchar
sino que a la gente que manifiesta su
juicio de manera legítima a través de
unos Diputados e incluso a través de los
sindicatos también critico a los
sindicatos él dijo nosotros estuvimos
abiertos los llamamos a negociar a
buscar un compromiso es decir un acuerdo
nosotros al comienzo dijimos 65 años los
bajamos a 64 pero los sindicatos nunca
hicieron otra contrapropuesta ellos Se
cerraron desde un primer momento dijo
Emmanuel macron también dijo que pese a
ello estaba nuevamente abierto a
invitarlos a negociar y a lograr
acuerdos en algunos temas lo que puede
considerarse como una suerte de anuncios
del presidente de Manuel concretamente
se refirió a las empresas que ganaron
mucho dinero durante la pandemia del
covid y sobre todo ahora con la
situación de la guerra dijo que esas
empresas que estaban reinvirtiendo sus
ganancias para comprar sus acciones para
aumentar el precio de estas pues ellas
debieran compartir esas ganancias con
sus trabajadores también dijo que habló
se refirió sobre las los trabajos duros
esos por ejemplo de los las personas que
recoge la limpieza dijo nosotros
entendemos que esa gente no puede llegar
hasta los 64 años trabajando así tan
duro pero tampoco a los 62 en realidad
esto hay que verlo mucho Antes tenemos
que trabajar en la reconversión de esas
personas mucho antes los 50 los 55 años
y también se refirió a aquellas personas
que dicen bueno Nosotros hemos trabajado
Y tenemos una pensión muy baja y gente
que no trabaja nunca que vive con eso
que se llama el salario solidario en
Francia y que van a recibir una pensión
como la mía pues dijo Bueno nosotros lo
que vamos a hacer es hacer trabajar esas
personas incentivar el trabajo de las
personas mayores para que no estén No es
cierto recibiendo ese salario solidario
Que también ellos trabajen coticen y por
lo tanto sea más justo luego que reciban
una buena pensión Esos fueron la suerte
de anuncios y obviamente confirmó lo que
ya se sabía que por lo menos por ahora
tiene ha dado la confianza a su primera
ministra Elizabeth y mientras tanto
Erika para mañana se prepara una nueva
jornada de manifestaciones que es lo que
se espera y bueno más después de esta
entrevista
Sí bueno los sindicatos no están
contentos las reacciones que hemos
podido escuchar Es que obviamente les
parece que el presidente sigue en esa
actitud un poco no es cierto muy seguro
de sí mismo y que no escucha a las
personas que se manifiestan y
menospreciando también esta movilización
masiva que no solamente tiene lugar en
París sino que en toda Francia
recordemos que también se refirió a las
requisiciones es decir a la obligación
de trabajar de las personas que recogen
la basura sobre todo de las grandes
ciudades donde hay problemas donde se
está acumulando la basura también en las
refinerías donde está habiendo problemas
de aprovisionamiento de combustible por
lo tanto mañana Se espera que sea una
gran movilización de hecho anoche ya
hubo una muy grande nuevamente en la
Plaza de la República de París lugar
emblemático Así que los sindicatos
mañana van a salir con más fuerza que
nunca porque consideran que este
presidente sigue sin escuchar a las
personas a la ciudadanía y un poco este
presidente de los ricos que se acerca a
la derecha para aprobar un proyecto que
justamente está muy marcado hacia la
derecha y no con respecto a las promesas
hechas durante su campaña